foreign
Kirk if you know Charlie or you don't
know Charlie
this is a man that's going to be a force
to be reckoned with for decades and
decades to come whether you love them or
hate them you're gonna have to deal with
them so if you're watching this because
you watched a couple of our podcasts and
you come in here because you like to
post some of the guests that we bring or
you support them this man's not going
away I had a chance to be at one of your
fundraisers a couple months ago I
watched you raise 41 I think it was 40.
I don't know the number I thought it was
40 or 41 million dollars is a lot in an
hour and a half and he is the founder of
Turning Point USA started it at 18 years
old
it's grown into a bunch of different
things that they're doing today uh uh
you you you you you like confrontation
you like you like debate you like banter
you like a good fight you're a fighter
that's the feeling I get from you so
it's great to have you on the podcast
I'm a big fan of yours Patrick's I love
your channel but more more importantly I
love your story
and I I love what you've created you
create a lot of value for a lot of
people I appreciate you and we've had
you our guys have had you had multiple
accounts one of the most amazing things
I mean it's hard to create things it's
hard to create big things it's hard to
create big things over a long period of
time and you've made a lot of people
wealthy and yourself wealthy because you
earned it and going to the event in
Vegas I think I did two one remote one
in person just hearing their stories
unbelievable I mean these are people
from every Walk of Life every background
and they have purpose and they have
meaning and they own their own business
and they're doing really substantial
things for themselves in their
communities so good on you yeah thank
you for that so for the audience that by
the way we have a Biz Doc in the house
as well we just came out of two board
meetings this morning back to back we
had to run I'm like Tom where are you
says I'm walking downstairs I sit
downstairs is now 59.90 and it was yet
to come over here uh this Thursday we're
gonna do a live podcast here we're in a
couple hundred people Giuliani will be
here Reuben will be here it'll be
interesting and then we got sauce cast
uh here with us as well Charlie for
people that don't know you if you don't
am I taking a moment and given a brief
background of how Charlie became Charlie
Kirk okay well first I didn't go to
college so that's important in the
biography
um I've been doing this it'll be 11
years in June uh running Turning Point
USA which is now the largest
organization of its kind in the entire
conservative movement
um my why why I do what I do is to try
to restore the promise of the American
founding to live in a free Society we
believe the Constitution is the greatest
political document ever written We
Believe America is the greatest nation
ever to exist and we believe we're
failing to teach that to young people
which is one of the many reasons why our
country's falling apart
um and then I also host a national radio
show every day which I'm actually taking
off today to help to be with you guys
and kind of just have a nice uh nice day
off and then also podcast which is one
of the top five conservative podcasts
out there and do a lot on social media
as well so so if I was in high school
with you 14 years old let's just say
we're in 10th Grade 15 years old yeah
who was Charlie in in 10th Grade I was
very political then uh and also
hyperactive so that hasn't changed uh
Eagle Scout football captain basketball
Captain didn't sit still well I
definitely would have been medicated if
I was in high school today
ADHD medication uh definitely but uh
some call it a gift some call it a
medical you know you have an issue but
blessing and a curse that's right so uh
but I try to channel it for the good
right uh that's what I love about living
in a free Society that's increasingly
less free but you can make something of
yourself in this country certainly I
want to piggyback on something you said
that I think was very powerful and I
don't want to just skip over it because
I believe you're 30 uh 29 29 so so
you're going to be 30 this year uh in
October yeah okay happy soon to be 30th
birthday yeah it's already 30 30. I
highly anticipated one of the things
that that is very disappointing to me as
someone just loves America left right up
down
is actually what you said about you know
young younger generation these days and
their lack of patriotism and lack of
appreciation for America the stats are
when it comes to polling
um as far as love of country and
patriotism Baby Boomers and older 73
love America proud to be American Gen X
56 Millennials 36 percent gen Z which I
don't know if you're gen Z or a
millennial you're younger Millennial far
worse than we are but yeah
15 percent
proud to be American so Pat completely
hit the nail on the head whether you
love you or hate you you're going to be
around for the next 30 50 plus years
opportunity wouldn't you say Patrick
exactly you've got a growth opportunity
it's in to try to get people to love the
country the people that are going to be
listening to you Charlie
are not the Boomers they're I mean
they're 65 75 plus it's going to be the
Millennials in gen Z how do you get them
to love America again and appreciate
your message yeah it's it's challenging
so I actually go to the Target
demographic themselves and I visit
campuses I speak with these students and
kids and praise God I mean our campus
tour this last uh semester was the most
successful we ever had we actually
couldn't find rooms big enough to fit
all the students that wanted to come to
our events which was great and look I
have very strong political opinions we
can talk about that if you guys want but
the basic core argument of why we love
America shouldn't be political which is
the American founding was an
unbelievable unique moment in human
history because it was reliant on some
classical observations of human nature
that made claims against tyranny in the
pursuit of Liberty that believing not in
sectarianism or tribalism but instead in
the individual and the Dignity of the
individual that is you can disagree at
this but the founders largely believed
that it was made in the image of the
Divine therefore there's worth and
there's Dignity of that person you don't
have to accept that but at least you can
accept the idea that you know the
individual is Sovereign and matters and
then you build a system around that that
has turned into the most amazing Society
ever to exist and now we're deciding to
end that so to your point two points yes
the younger generation has deep
resentment for the nation for because
they're taught that in the government
schools and they're taught that in
popular media and secondly
um they don't understand or they cannot
properly articulate why this is the
greatest nation ever to exist in the
history of the world and there's great
reasons for it it's my job to try to
convince them and educate them albeit in
15 to 20 second sound bites with the
attention span decreasing but I believe
you know my purpose is to try to make
sure my daughter who's seven months old
lives in a free society and we are
currently heading in the wrong direction
very quickly okay so let's go with that
let's go with that because uh you know a
lot of people are following Tate Tate
became the most viral person on the
internet uh him and I were speaking when
he got out of jail and you know they're
now on house arrest and we're having a
conversation about some of the things
that's going on uh he went from evolve
from being a guy that was an atheist as
a young guy coming up okay then he
started seeing what the Christian you
know Christian denomination was doing
and what they stood for said these are
interesting principles kind of welcomed
it then he partially lost respect in the
Christian religion the denomination that
started compromising and saying yeah
we'll accept this we'll accept that
we'll accept this what about this and
then he says the only religion that
seems to not break when it comes down to
their values as Muslim and then he went
and became a Muslim and that's what he
supports now that may be extreme to you
but the part that when I talked to a lot
of the youngins who are following him
and following what he's saying that
argument is a good argument to say if
you are going to be a conservative if
you are going to be a Christian well
your church is starting to say yeah it's
okay Pope it's okay you can come in as
long as you bring money you can come and
you can come in versus the Muslims
saying hey you can't so what what do you
say to the criticism the West is getting
by a lot of people saying the West is no
longer what it once was and it's past
the Tipping Point meaning there's no
longer a saving of the West what do you
say the first part you're probably right
I mean we're in a complete terminal
decline
and it's hard to disagree with that a
moral decline economic decline Financial
decline fiscal decline I don't think
we're past the Tipping Point to the
Andrew Tate part I think that's a bad
reason to convert to Islam I don't think
there's a good reason to convert to
Islam but because there's plenty of
uncompromising Christian churches but
generally yes it is true that a lot of
Christian denominations are becoming
more like the world than not following
the word happy to talk more about that
if you want but that that is the
question is where is the West and you
kind of gotta have to take a pulse
there's plenty of reasons for optimism
I'm seeing a kind of renewed sense of
patriotism and certain sex I'm seeing
what we're doing at Turning Point USA
I'm seeing parents get more involved in
school boards at the same time we're
living through what Nietzsche predicted
in the 1860s 1870s and 1880s where he
did not Proclaim it but he stated God is
dead and the next and again that's it's
misquoted because people think he was
celebrating the death of God he was not
but he he was saying is that hey you in
the west if you are going to replace god
with consumerism and the Industrial
Revolution and Hyper individualism be
careful what's going to take its place
and we're kind of living through the
kind of mixture of synthetic worldviews
that take its place when Christianity or
a cogent Western morality uh
deteriorates so what do I say to the
compromising Christians well stop
compromising and then I I wouldn't also
necessarily say that Islam is attractive
as a substitute of that but I'm happy to
explore that it's not about it's not
about the substitute of that because
they uh there's some stats we looked at
a couple months ago on a podcast we had
this guy that was talking about how deep
you know underpopulation is the problem
not overpopulation how the world can
handle and you know and then we looked
up the numbers on the podcast and we saw
I'm going to be wrong by a couple
percentage points but pretty close
within a couple percent out of a hundred
people that are born
in the world 33 were Christians 31 were
Muslims
but out of a hundred people that die in
the world 32 were Christians only 10
were Muslims
which means the young you know Muslims
are having more kids and they're a lot
younger which means by 2035 the world
will be led by Muslims having more
Muslims in the world than Christians and
why do you think that message because a
lot of times you see that message and
all you think about is well the first
thing we think about is also Muslim
extremists I mean every Muslim is a
Muslim extremist which is not it's a
smaller sect of the majority but if if
the if the messaging what are they doing
that they're messaging is more
attractive were NBA players football
players Hollywood some people are
starting to say well I'm kind of going
to lean towards this then Christianity
Today I don't think we have to speculate
I don't know if you have Cassius Clay up
there which was his name before Muhammad
Ali yes or Kareem Abdul we do we
actually got Sunday up there yeah the
idea of man Dave Chappelle by the way
yeah Dave ship is is he is is he I
believe so is that right I didn't know
that Tyson what Tyson yeah the idea
especially black men being drawn to the
Muslim faith is not new because it
really does it's Unapologetic in the
patriarchy right so in a hyper feminist
World it seems attractive and again I
mean Malcolm X wrote extensively about
this I I mean I don't subscribe to a lot
of the appeal of it because Islam is not
true in my world view but that's we
could discuss that I don't think it's
actually useful of our time today but
you're you're hitting on something
really important Patrick in a world that
has gone mad in chaos people you're in
for order
now you could be too far in the order
Direction which I think Islam goes too
far I do not want to live in a
Theocratic fascist country I like how
freedom of speech I like having dialogue
I like private property rights I like
entrepreneurship that's why I think the
West is the best because you balance
order with spontaneity and
unpredictability if you just want order
you can live in Saudi Arabia but that's
not a free Society
and but I think the West has gone way
too far away from having order as a
Bedrock principle what the founders
tried to establish in the Constitution
especially because of the world that
they built it in is how do we have
Liberty but also we have the rootedness
of Eternal wisdom so that Liberty does
not become licentiousness
and that's exactly what we're living
through is that it's no longer the
pursuit of what is good it's the pursuit
of what makes me feel good and those are
two different things so people like Tate
or people previously in the 60s or 70s I
mean you could list a lot of people that
convert to Islam because it's very
attractive because the strong man
archetype is not just president Islam it
is demanded in Islam that the man is the
not just the head of the home the head
of the society and so it's very
attractive in a world that's gone mad I
think that's the wrong answer to be just
to be clear but I can understand why
certain people would be gravitated
towards so who who would you say today
is the most famous
non-pastor Christian in the world that's
getting others to say I also want to be
a Christian I don't mean Joel Osteen I
don't mean if you go to some of the big
pastors that we have I'm not talking
about that I'm talking about a guy
that's in Hollywood that's in the NBA
that's in the MLB that's in music who
are some of the biggest ones that are
converting that are converting I mean I
maybe Tim Tebow but he's not exactly as
successful but you're pinpointing
something really powerful here which I
totally agree with first of all if you
find I mean Justin Bieber is not exactly
someone I would consider theologically
sound right but at least he says good
things about Jesus but the Christian
world is lacking in the cultural figures
that embrace the world view whereas in
the 50s or 60s you had John Wayne
you had every major act not every but
you had Joe DiMaggio you had before that
Babe Ruth that were outspoken Christians
and now you look in the world it's
either secularism or just kind of as
agnosticism and any Christian celebrity
that might be outspoken they have to
always preface it with social liberalism
I would say maybe Mark Wahlberg he's
done a person who's gonna say Wahlberg
you saw what he did on I think that's
beautiful what he's done with it you
know the Catholic faith move to Nevada
explain why he moved out of L.A to go to
Nevada with his family and he's thinking
about turning Vegas into the next
Hollywood he even just caught some heat
of course he did he's just doing this
Wednesday they say he's a gay hater or
whatever but but that but this is
exactly where I'm going with this yeah
so where I'm going with this is the
following is so uh so what image right
there whereas a lot of people who are uh
um
Christians will go and they'll go in a
community that's safe and they'll talk
to one another where it's a safe place
whereas Muslims we'll go out there and
they'll baptize and they'll convert
where you know if you if you look at the
two and you'll say well one is staying
quiet about it the other one's being
bold about it one is advertising why he
is the other one is not but at the same
time the media will defend Muslim but
the media will not defend Christianity
the the sports teams will say Hey you
have to be a little bit more
understanding about the Muslim religion
about Christianity they can get shots so
how did that happen the evolution of
where Christianity went hey the
judeo-christian the Christian great
nation America look at the values and
principles that we have where did the
fall happen boy that that's a powerful
question it's hard to pinpoint a certain
year but they're certainly an era in the
60s or 70s these revolutionaries took
control of a lot of Institutions and the
Zeitgeist the spirit of the times got
perverted and changed
I encourage anybody to find me a Netflix
Amazon or Hulu documentary or film in
the last 10 years that portrays someone
that is a Christian in a positive light
and in fact this was pinpointed recently
I can't remember who an actor came out
um and he said hey guys why is it the
pastor always has to be like the abuser
or the embezzler or the and you think
about the archetype right the archetype
is if you see a Bible in an Amazon film
you almost can assure that that person
is gonna be a villain or at the very
least a hypocrite rarely is that the
person that is going to be acting
ethically acting morally and that's a
complete change and it's done rather
subversibly right in our in our culture
and so but here's the thing kind of the
post post 60s world view the moral view
that came in in the post 60s and it
didn't really set in until now it took
60 years is hyper individualism and I'm
all for entrepreneurship and for people
to succeed but you must balance that you
must counterbalance it with Duty and
obligations if it's all about just the
pursuit of your own pleasures and your
own Delights you will be not just empty
I think you're going to be miserable and
so we build an entire Society I think on
this very dangerous moral pretext and we
wonder why we have the most depressed
suicidal anxious generation in history I
I totally sympathize with every
accusation of American Christianity that
you could imagine they could be
hypocritical their churches are too big
they don't give enough to the poor I
think some of that is a little silly but
it is a fact that as we have turned our
back on American Christianity with the
roots of it that we are less free we are
more confused and we are filling it with
these other fake religions that we could
talk about the religion of anti-racism
the religion of scientism right even
Earth worship at times which is hyper
you know global warming yeah
environmentalism and so there's a great
book by Tom Holland he calls it Dominion
it's not a great title but he it Holland
with an e but yeah it's how the how
Christians remade uh revolutionize the
world I encourage everyone to read it
and he's actually a secular agnostic who
argues that what we consider to be
common sense what we consider to be
normal is a traditional inheritance from
the Christian
history and you might not like
Christianity you might not believe Jesus
is the king of the world I do but you
should at least accept that if you
remove Christianity as the Bedrock of
your civilization be careful what you
fill it with because currently we're
filling it with garbage yeah so so a
couple things based on what you just
said one I I saw Andrew Schultz the
other day you know Andrew Schultz the
comedian I don't know if you're familiar
with Andrew Schultz yeah he's he's to me
I think he's one of the most talented
comedians I can watch his Clips on
replay and the guy makes me laugh over
and over again there's only a couple
guys that make me do that I've probably
seen his Clips you know who he is he's
he's incredible he said the other day he
went to church yeah he's great and he
says he went to church the other day he
says in the first three minutes of being
in church he started crying this isn't
that's not his brand at all Andrew
Schultz's brand is not too this was an
attack no this was not a joke he was
being serious about it right now if you
go to the Justin Bieber story and we can
go to Hillsdale you know not Hillsdale
but uh Hillsong and all that stuff
Australia yeah I saw a lot of it yeah so
a lot of that the challenge then becomes
also to say sometimes the you know it's
overly judgmental on who's going to be
the Christian to help bring the brand
and you know bring others towards it
there's a challenge with that as well
but you know for me I saw Wall Street
journal's article recently came out with
values I'm sure you saw that as well
yeah the collapse of the American values
patriotism that's right involvement
having children and going to church have
just descended in meaning but money is
up money is up yeah and that's that
hyper individualism that's what you were
talking about again I am a capitalist I
think that markets work but they must be
in harmony with other duties that make
the money meaning meaningful otherwise
it's just nothing more than pleasure or
things that will erode and dust so it
must Point towards something you must
aim high that was the Western ideal
right and that's why the Declaration is
such a beautiful document it mentions
God four times and in fact act in the
end of The Declaration it's basically a
prayer we don't teach this to our kids
it's an appeal it says we appeal to the
Supreme judge of the world and they're
pointing High to something larger than
themselves it's very platonic to use a
phrase that was earlier that there's
things that we can't quite feel that
cannot be looked at in a you know cannot
be looked at in a microscope but we know
they're real we know love we know
Justice we know Mercy we know kindness
we know compassion is real and in fact
we need to build a society around that
with the post-modernists and the
post-structuralists have done post 1960s
is they basically say if it's not
Material if you can't see it and cause
an effect it's not real
and that's that's a that's a tragedy to
believe and so yes the the byproduct to
that is so you have two things happening
at once America pulls back from its
values that wants to find can you go to
the uh
it's very powerful but then the they
kind of buried the lead in fact they
didn't incorporate it which I just want
to reiterate it is a fact that we are
the most depressed most suicidal most
anxious most medicated most alcohol
addicted in history now you might say
well Charlie that's causation and
correlation hard to say that they aren't
connected hard to say that if patriotism
religion Community involvement having
kids collapses and all the negative
indicators Skyrocket that there isn't
some sort of relationship there what Tom
what do you think needs to happen for uh
uh a man to get on his knees and say I
need God what do you think needs to
happen for that to take place to a
nation great crisis builds great
response in the heart of any man after 9
11 you saw the unification of America in
an amazing way because whenever you have
a great crisis you you will inherently
point back to a great tenet or a great
truth and what happened on 9 11 the
great truth was Nobody messes with the
greatest country in the world and I'm
part of that and I'm proud to be part of
that and I'm coming together with my
neighbors and I'm upset about this and
I'm healing together and I'm mourning
together and I'm angry together together
the word together keeps coming and age
of moral relativism as we see here
everybody's truth is okay so starting in
1968 69 if you were to study that there
were about four things that came
together that make it very
understandable for a crack in the heart
of the populace in the population one is
you know you have the death of Bobby
Kennedy the death of Martin Luther King
You've Got The Summer of Love you've got
the senseless these people that believe
the senseless sending to war of um of
our young men if you if you didn't get
into college you're going to war tough
you know if you manage to get into
college oh so if your family could get
you into college you don't have to go to
war well you know talk to algor and W
about that they both took advantage of
that privilege to stay out of the war
and there was this crack that happened
there you had the loss of these leaders
you had the also the loss of faith in
the in the in the Elders of the time
because what was happening there and the
great Summer of Love where everybody
thought well then all your truths will
be okay that was well intended but what
happened in the middle of that is if
everybody's truth is okay pbd then
there's no one ruler for standard for
morals there's no one ruler for
standards of what is patriotism what is
faith in America or what is good or what
do we do for a community and suddenly
everybody's truth is okay and you can't
judge me becomes the the boomerang that
comes back the unintended consequences
is you lose control of the whole thing
and so I think great crisis is needed
what will bring America back together
and unfortunately great crises are
usually very painful in their own right
can I say of course that was really
beautifully put I'm you I didn't even
think about the college enrollment draft
thing prior the issue though Patrick is
that if you have moral chaos tyranny
comes next and there's a totalitarian
impulse that is running through our
country we call it identity politics
political correctness is that the the
the the answer to this will not be more
freedom or more Liberty in the short
term it's that it's going we're going to
need instruments of meaning so then
we're going to need somebody to tell you
what to do which is one of the reasons
why I think this covidian fascism was
accepted by so many Americans for so
long and so you get strong leaders quote
unquote strong leaders if the moral
fiber of your country decays if I can
just add to that I
I believe everything you're saying is
accurate I also think that there's sort
of a messaging problem because
you talked about the Joel Osteen's of
the world or even the Mark Wahlberg's of
the world
who do you think is more likely to
convert the everyday person to love
America and to fear God again Joel
Osteen or a Mark Wahlberg type I would
argue that you need this in the pop
culture Zeitgeist it's not going to take
a religious leader or some sort of
apostle that's going to convert everyday
Americans and start loving Americans
again or go to church more often it's
not going to be a religious leader you
see the fastest growing religion in
America these days is atheism and
agnosticism right non-denominational or
just non-believer yes
um so we need to kind of like what
you're saying we need to make loving
America again and American values and
judeo-christian values pop culture and
cool again and until that's done I think
we're going to have the same
conversation for years and years ago my
argument is that the American founding
is the great rallying point I think that
it's so beautiful it's so exceptional
it's so rare in human history and it
also I think people yearn to actually
love the place they live in I know
that's an unusual thing to say I think
people actually want an excuse to love
America and so I think the promise of
the founding can be that great unifying
that you could disagree on tax policy
disagreeing immigration but let's at
least agree that these Founders were
onto something very big bold and
beautiful and we're recipients from and
then understand what that is we got a
real conversation about that if I can
give you one thing for that if that's
the answer which it might okay which it
is so you remember the movie The Patriot
yeah Mel Gibson by the way is a
Christian that would be I mean talk
about what happened to him after passion
to the Christ yeah well he's doing
number two now yeah but that movie I
don't know if that uh preceded Passion
of the Christ before and Braveheart are
you kidding me yeah but that guy made
loving America and fighting for America
cool and in the pop culture so it's
going to take something like that kind
of what I was saying in the pop culture
to make Young Americans 16 is not proud
to be American you're not going to get
him to start loving America by saying
hey read the Declaration of Independence
buddy I acknowledge that yeah I'm not
even trust me try to get them to read
the the preamble to the Constitutions
let alone the first paragraph of one of
the course human events that comes
necessary when people dissolve the
political bans that have time to another
to get them to even read that like what
does that even mean I'm talking about
the Eternal compelling truth behind it
right that maybe and if not then we're a
lot farther gone than I would like to
believe but I totally agree I mean Tom
Cruise's top gun Maverick praise God
that that was the number one movie in
the last year and a half yeah I think
that is evidence in my favor that people
enjoyed kind of the pro Americana Vibe
right the kind of you know we're gonna
go up against the bad guys there was no
bad guy who named the bad guy no that's
what it was interesting there was no
country they didn't identify it almost
it was just about America intentionally
abstract almost right and it was about
rallying behind a team and it really
didn't Pander that much to Identity
politics I mean it was a little bit
throughout but it was largely a movie
that could have been made in the 80s or
90s which is why it was so successful
you know you know you know what I think
needs to happen this is my ideas okay on
this first of all for me uh uh the enemy
if you study enemy how it did whatever
it did it always divided if I if a if a
person today we're having a meeting
upstairs we're having a managers meeting
and I said the biggest challenge in a in
a marriage who's the biggest enemy in a
marriage the biggest enemy is when the
spouse becomes the marriage it's always
better to have an external enemy than an
internal enemy the worst type of enemy
is the internal enemy we have internal
enemies right now and the way they're
doing it is they they're going they're
so brilliant dark but brilliant they're
going straight to the top of influence
and they're crippling them
straight to the top but did you see what
he did but did you see what she did but
your parents they don't know what
they're doing your parents don't care
about you if your parents came out they
would probably judge you you know what
this is how we are we are a little bit
more desperate so they're dividing to
the point of influence okay whatever the
influence is now Mel Gibson may be a guy
who I can watch all day his movies I
think is fantastic I think it's funny he
can do funny I think he can do you know
drama he can do anything put him
anywhere he's going to do great right
but I think you need to get somebody
like the face of the NBA the face of the
NFL the face of Hollywood like it needs
to be a rock type it needs to be a
Michael type a LeBron type A Brady type
a person like that that's willing to
talk so if they're gonna work that way
to come and take the influence from the
top you got to go get some of the guys
at the top so two things Mahomes is an
outspoken Christian so that's a good
start and I know for certain he loves
America he's probably a conservative I
don't want to out him here because he
would lose a contract and boy isn't that
the case is that they make harsh
punishment Swift
if you defect from the regime party line
and just look at what happens if you
dare even step out of line a little bit
you have to do these long apologies and
you have to I mean look what they try to
do to Rogan for even questioning some of
the covid stuff right you got to stand
up though but no I agree with you I'm
saying that the people too big to cancel
the Mahomes the and Brady is a right
winger I mean he's a total pro-american
conservative guy and he you know he's
too big to cancel now he's retired so
maybe he'll really speak out more but I
completely agree I mean Tiger Woods is a
is a pro-american guy you know he
doesn't hate this country I'm sure he
doesn't stand for the BLM stuff there's
a difference between being what you are
and promoting it and driving it there's
a big difference between being what you
are and driving it and promoting it
because other young kids are watching
you to want to be converted anyways we
got a lot of the stories I want to get
into a few things Tom I'm looking at
Wall Street Journal today top three
stories Elon Musk has revived the idea
of digital banking to turn Twitter into
a company worth more than 250 billion
dollars in aspiration that faces
regulatory hurdles and challenge of
entrenched players Second Story Tesla
delivered a record number of vehicles in
the three months of the year first three
months of the year when the company
slashed prices to stimulate demand in a
cooling car market okay three McDonald's
is temporarily closing its U.S offices
this week as It prepares to inform
corporate employees about layoffs
undertaken by the burger giant as part
of a broader company restructuring top
going to uh Elon Musk operating those
two companies Tesla and Twitter what are
the likelihood you think because right
now Twitter's what they came back the
shares they're showing 22 billion
dollars valuation whatever the number
was a guy like this running two
different companies what's the
likelihood of both of these things
becoming a reality meaning Tesla going
to become the company he wants to build
and Twitter become that quarter billion
dollar comp quarter trillion Auto
Company
well I I look at his background and if
you told me that he was going to make
those four companies successful when you
add you know space exploration and other
things to it I would have said you're
crazy but I think this is this guy's
just a special guy and I think he's
putting the teams around him he's been
unafraid to
um call The Herd at Twitter headquarters
and I think both of these things are
going to be a reality and he's not going
to do it single-handedly and what he's
doing right now is he is pulling back on
Twitter and then Building forward with
the people that are with him and I think
both of these things are absolutely
going to be a reality and you have to
remember where he's going with Twitter
it's it's not really a long path to that
it's called the super app and we see
people talking about the super apps that
are available that do so many things
yeah and that are also banking centers
and I think he's uh you know been part
of a past organization that comes to
mind I think that was uh a pretty
successful Center of banking and I think
what he's really talking about here is
I'm going to make Twitter a super app
and I'm also going to make Tesla
successful and I believe him should I
come out and say that did he want to
make this into a super app he's talked
about it before he said that before yeah
so a question for you Charlie so imagine
what if let's do three what ifs okay
what if musk doesn't buy Twitter what if
Spotify dropped Rogan what if there is
no Rumble what would happen today if
there weren't for those three companies
uh we we would be in a
far far worse spot than we are now yeah
I mean if must then buy Twitter first of
all I would have been able to prove that
I was on a Twitter Blacklist because
Elon put out the Twitter do not amplify
tag so that's number one praise God we
have you know that I did not know that
yeah who else was on that list Dan
bongino that we know of uh it's actually
my pin tweet it says I was placed on
Twitter's Blacklist
you you learned that just a few months
ago one of the Twitter
files that was leaked and reported On by
Barry Weiss
showed that there was a specific threat
assessment tag put on my Twitter account
that said quote do not amplify on my
account it was a shadow ban without a
shadow ban so Jack Dorsey lied under
oath in front of Congress so you weren't
banned you just weren't Amplified yeah
it said do not amplify yeah to a day I
could show you because we used to have
the fourth largest engaged Twitter
account on the planet according to axios
we were averaging about 135 000 retweets
a day we really understood the harmony
of the platform and we used it non-stop
it's kind of how we made a name for
ourselves and then like overnight we
went to a thousand retweets a day and we
now know why because we were placed on a
Twitter big difference but from 135 to a
thousand retweets a day it's a scale of
a hundred right you saw the same thing
on Tick Tock Pat saw the exact same
thing oh they did the same thing as well
Pat and I were talking to each other do
you remember the uh the termination day
where they where all of a sudden a bunch
of followers disappeared Pat and I were
on the phone call the pat have you
looked at your your Twitter I just
looked at mine I just lost 3 000
followers from yesterday to today and
now you can go back and do can look at
any of The Trackers in here uh you know
social blade or any of them then you can
scrape it but the point is the fact that
go back I actually want you to think
about it let's let's try to paint a
picture for the audience musk doesn't
buy Twitter
Spotify drops Rogan
Rumble isn't there to scare the crap out
of YouTube saying hey if you don't if
you abuse the talent there's another
option for that okay what does America
look like if those three events don't
happen you would look even more like
East Germany and we're looking like East
Germany right now I mean it Rumble is
one of our Great Hopes for free speech
online full disclosure I'm a shareholder
in Rumble I bought their stock so I'm
not pushing the stock I'm just saying
what they're doing is a very very
magical thing to push back against the
Leviathan that is YouTube If Spotify
would have canceled Rogan he probably
would have landed on his feet he
probably could have done his own thing
but it would have showed that we at
Spotify will not allow any sort of
dissident opinions or dissent I
personally think Rogan might not renew
his Spotify contract I would love to see
him do his own thing and just
send out his stuff I think he's big
enough he's he's America's greatest
podcaster he's super easy to listen to
Fabulous interviewer and just really
interesting that's my own personal
opinion I think he's bigger than Spotify
in fact I I was one of the few people
that think that Spotify underpaid him I
think he's a billion dollar Talent I'm I
know that sounds wild but he has so much
power in the Zeitgeist he's so good at
what he does and not to mention he can
get any guest he wants at any time and
he has a unique format so those three
those components praise God that Twitter
is now owned by Elon it's Freer than
ever before there's still a lot of work
to do on the platform it's still not it
still has sort of quirks and I don't
like their new verification thing it
drives me crazy that almost anybody can
get verified but that's just me I think
it's kind of weird
um but speech online believe it or not
in the last year has become more free
not less free of course it's one of the
few things in society that's actually
heading the right direction which is why
they have to try to get this restrict
Act passed
the restrict act in DC where they're
saying it's going to ban Tick Tock it's
all nonsense what they're trying to do
is create a precedent or a prerequisite
to make speech less free online
we as people that love America and
believe in dialogue in a free and open
internet have actually had a pretty good
18 months they're going to try to use
the bipartisan hatred of tick tock as a
way to try to ban telegram Rumble and
Twitter all three of them have foreign
components telegram was founded by a
Russian Rumble was founded in Canada and
Twitter has shareholders like the Saudis
that own shares under the restrict act
the Secretary of Commerce could ban all
three
based on what they're about to give the
power to and it's probably going to pass
thankfully because we're sounding the
alarm on it's the Patriot Act on
steroids for social media yeah look it's
right there I mean that's the actual
that's literally the quote and that's
salon.com which is a communist rag that
even agrees with me I mean I hate Tick
Tock I think it's digital fentanyl but I
think that we're gonna have to live with
Tick Tock being a thing maybe sold to an
American company and onshore that would
be the best solution because giving DC
unprecedented censorship Authority in a
time when the internet is becoming Freer
would be a big mistake you think Tick
Tock should be banned is that something
in the ideal world of course yes but we
we have to also look in reality where
you give DC a little bit of this power
they're going to use it to ban Us in
another way I think Tick Tock is bad for
society and bad for Humanity but I don't
always get what I want so I'd rather
have a free open internet with this
really bad app that hopefully can be on
board in America because they will try
to use the same power to then restrict
telegram rumble or Twitter but is there
is there this yearning for this would
you what act is it called the restrict
act oh yeah I know it has
who's leading that um Republicans and
Democrats you can look at the
co-sponsors there's more Republicans
actually than Democrats sponsoring it
um Lindsey Graham Shelley Moore capito
Susan Collins you can go through all the
co-sponsors or John Foon is the main
Republican yep there it is John thune
and then uh Tammy Baldwin from Wisconsin
I'm super cynical and jaded anytime you
have mass bipartisan support for
anything in DC means a lot of lobbyists
are pushing for something that's
probably going to be bad for the country
and our freedom I hate to be so jaded
but that's just a general rule and
there's exceptions obviously I mean
there's some opioid stuff that's passing
that's some good legislation this is
confirmation of the rule though this is
an awful piece of legislation
um that would make our ability to speak
online highly restricted because it's
literally in the name the restrict act
so what could they do to companies so
forget Tick Tock what could they do to a
rumble what could they do to read the
bill it's on if they could police our
speech it is Patriot Act 2.0 using the
guys of foreign adversaries giving all
the power to the Secretary of Commerce
who's no one really knows who she is
she's Gina raimondo it's fine it could
be anybody but effectively delegating
that authority to say if there's any
sort of foreign policy concern
we can then use that power to close down
the app restrict their activity or
monitor the activity and you could just
imagine and by the way the people
pushing this are the tech companies
Google and Facebook I said why would
Google and Facebook push this well
Google is being threatened via YouTube
shorts with Tick Tock Facebook is being
threatened on Instagram by Tick Tock but
Facebook wants more than that Facebook
would love to be able to ban telegram
because people would use WhatsApp this
is all blatant cronyism disguised as a
bipartisan Bill to try to stop the CCP
from mining our kids data we should try
to do something to fix that make them
onshore it sell it to an American
company the idea of giving the federal
government censorship powers of a social
media app I think it's a really bad idea
for me for me it came down when I went
to look at this and I was expecting to
see a like a five-page tariff right
tariffs are usually three to five pages
aluminum shall be defined as a aluminum
and it will have a 16 tariff and within
five pages you take care of it so I was
expecting Pat to see five pages on this
because of the threat posed by a foreign
entity having access to personal
information including potential
financial information of the American
people it shall be impugned right that's
the word you look for I was looking for
five pages and also when you're looking
this is hundreds wait a minute why does
it need why do you need hundreds of
pages to effectively put a negative
tariff and to shut Tick Tock for the
reasons of harvesting American
information on foreign soil for
nefarious means and then I looked into
it and I said wait a minute this is a
whole this is a weaponization of
government that is being advocated by by
today's corporate interests coming from
Facebook what Facebook doesn't
understand is there's another side of
the rock here because they're not going
to be where they are forever nor their
competitors going to be are forever and
they are one generation in a Black Swan
from being on the receiving end of this
thing
hundreds of pages it'll be a five-page
tariff
the next concern we can get uh this this
is a while because we saw what Patriot
Act did it's a way of bullying the
average person and going after anybody
at any given time and I've had a chance
to interview a lot of these Mobsters it
was done from a good standpoint to get
them you know put them in jail and a lot
of these guys at New York City was very
happy the fact that Rudy was able to do
it but then that opened up a way for the
government to say man we can really go
after a lot of different people go after
Trump everybody he was the Patriot Act
to go after Trump as president yeah so
let's talk about that what's going on
right now with Trump
um I can pick any of these stories and
and read them you Trump rages about
being indicted in social media posts
about his indictment says the US is now
a third world country you know uh Donald
Trump can still run for president after
him yeah I know indicated I saw that
indicator he wrote that yeah yeah if I
was indicted I wouldn't have my spelling
very personally I think we've got to
give him a little bit so what are your
thoughts about what's going on what are
your thoughts about what's going on here
oh I mean it's it's an outrage I mean
it's I called it something similar to a
legal Pearl Harbor where this has never
been done before we'll never forget that
it's done and there first of all they're
directly interfering with an election
you don't like Trump beat him at The
Ballot Box why do you have to do it this
way second of all this is not a felony
what they've outlined we haven't seen
the indictment yet so maybe I'll be
corrected but I don't think I will be in
this way based on all public reporting
and all leaks from the grand jury this
is a paperwork area era that might be a
misdemeanor might and upgraded to a
felony while Alvin Bragg has downgraded
52 of previously classified felonies as
misdemeanors so the trend in New York is
not felonies we're going in the
misdemeanor direction we're going to you
know we're going to say that if you loot
or if you burn or you steal or you do
all these things yeah reduced by 52
percent
um that yes downgraded 52 percent of
felony cases to misdemeanors compared to
39 so it's it's 11 different yeah yeah
and so he's increasing it now and so
there's a term for this I didn't come up
with it it's Sam Francis called anarcho
tyranny which is the basic things that
the nation needs to do to keep yourself
safe
holding murders accountable drug
trafficking arson stuff that we all
don't agree with that we're loosening
the sentencing and the policing there
but we're increasing the Tyranny for
political favored crimes
and so of course the political hit job
they're using this for political
purposes but I think there's a I think
there's something a lot deeper here
going on
the real crime that Donald Trump
committed was winning the 2016 election
and we know this in the psychological
literature the power of trauma right and
we know we know about post-traumatic
stress syndrome PTSD it's not that
different they were the left in New York
the New York City Elite were
legitimately traumatized the night that
Hillary Clinton was supposed to break
that glass ceiling at the Kravitz Center
and that has now become almost a
psychologically defining event for them
were they sort of they swore a Blood
Oath seven years ago we're gonna get you
and it's gonna no matter what we're
gonna make you indicted in the same
place that you stole that night from us
because Amy Coney Barrett and Kavanaugh
and Gorsuch and all the successes that
Donald Trump achieved was not supposed
to happen so I think this is more a
Revenge than almost anything else it's
Petty it's personal it's pathological
and it's political Daily Mail says Trump
doubles his lead in Republican primary
record-breaking you know raising money
people are coming out of supporting him
some people are saying no matter what
he's going to end up winning story came
out that they want him to be uh he wants
him to do 30 days in jail they're trying
to get him to go do time for a gag order
for a gag order yes all of this stuff
that's going on now here here's kind of
how I process this you know if you if
you go after someone's father and you
kill someone's father but he's got two
three surviving Sons it's game over you
know back in the days if you took out a
guy you had to take out his sons because
you did not want any Revenge to be
taking place let's say you win with
Trump
let's say they win with Trump what
they're doing let's say they do
how many people have they given birth to
or waken up right now that are saying
now that you did this watch to see what
we're gonna do 10 20 30 years from now
yeah that's a rational argument and they
don't think that way I mean look the the
whatever you want to call it the Deep
State the elite left taking out
Presidents by non-democratic means has
been done before
they did it to Nixon
right they attempted to do it to Clinton
and he survived in a lot because he made
a deal I think with the National
Security State they've done this Obama
was smart enough not to wage war on the
security did whatever the CIA wanted
whatever the FBI wanted and then they
tried to do it to Trump three times
first with the Patriot Act precedent or
the fisa court
which was completely unconstitutional
where James Comey and Peter struck
stroke smirk they colluded together
illegally to get a fisa warrant to spy
on a sitting president's soon to be
president's campaign and also then a
sitting president and trap Michael Flynn
then the first impeachment over a phone
call then the second impeachment over
January 6th I mean this guy has been
attacked at every possible
non-democratic Vector you can imagine
because I think there is a fear that
they will not be able to replicate what
they did in 2020 again
whether you think it was fraud which I
certainly believe or not we can all
agree what happened in 2020 was unusual
that's that's a fact it was the amount
of mail-in ballots the amount of private
money from Zuckerberg 400 million
dollars drop boxes kind of confusion no
one really knew what was happening with
kovid and it was almost like the Make It
Stop election I think there's a great
fear that Trump might win in 2024 and we
have to take him off the chessboard
immediately consequences be damned for
for someone like you where you are where
uh uh I by the way these two screens
Jorge went down if you want to bring
them back up we don't see them so for
someone like you I was at your event
when I was at the event and I was
watching some of the people saying hey
four million dollars two million dollars
hundred thousand dollars you know half a
million dollars
and and you saw some folks that said hey
uh some of you are worried about wanting
to give money because you're thinking
you know Charlie's a part of a trump
camp or this or that and some of you are
DeSantis people here whether you are or
you're not you know he is doing some
values that are good for the how are you
positioned right now to be where you are
you got Trump it's a very complicated
position you're in because uh you know
the smile on your face it says a story
because on one side it's never a dull
moment yeah it's never a dull moment but
you're in a you're in a pickle here
yourself so how do you maneuver around a
situation like this yeah I try to be as
clear as possible first Turning Point
USA the the Crux of what we do is
educational it's 501c3 no political At
All by law we have to stay out of
politics high school campuses college
campuses Turning Point Academy TP USA
Faith young women's Leadership Summit
thousands and thousands of members
that's going to remain strong and
growing and one of the largest organized
nations in the country praise God and
then there's Charlie Kirk personally
I've endorsed Trump in 2024. I don't
like his attacks on DeSantis I don't
support them because I actually like
Governor DeSantis a lot and I want him
to be successful but when I'm clear to
my donors about this you know we've lost
I'd say probably 10 or 12 major donors
saying I don't like the factor behind
Trump I'm like well I'm sorry let me
tell you why first he was a great
president
secondly I want to understand that
Charlie Kirk and the Turning Point
machine would not exist if it was not
for how generous Donald Trump was to us
throughout the years Patrick I was 24
years old sitting in the Oval Office as
a non-college graduate getting invited
on Air Force One
if I if I would forget that I mean I
would be the most ungrateful
short-sighted person to turn my back on
the man who believed in me when I was
not nearly as you know let's just say
successful or popular as I am today and
so I I have an obligation to him in the
best possible way I don't want to be one
of those people that benefits and turns
the back and I also have something to
say about that a lot of people talk
about Trump's negatives I hear about all
the time but he has some virtues some
great virtues he works relentlessly I've
never seen someone with as much energy
as him he loves the country he's
amazingly patriotic he's very creative
and honestly he was a fabulous president
and he might not like the tone but look
at where America was when he was
president and the garbage that's going
on now it's pretty easy choice so what
you just said is the Loyalty you're
staying loyal under him and he was loyal
to you yes and I also think he was a
great president and I believe in his
eyes I respect that now what do you say
to people that say well that's great
Charlie we respect that but that's
exactly what his problem is we would run
because he thinks without himself Ron
would have never won and that is why
some people from Mega believe that he is
disloyal unlike you what do you say to
those people
so what you're asking is what do I say
to people that say that Trump gets mad
at Ron because he's disloyal or yeah no
so I'll have a conversation I'll say
listen guys there's a reason why I'm in
Florida I mean I lived in La for 20 some
years and I lived in Dallas for five
years we're in Florida we're in Florida
because we watched all the governors are
in covert what they did Ron crushed it
we felt like this is the place we're
going to build the media headquarters we
moved out here kids values principles
all of that we felt good here right and
the beach in Florida is much better than
the beach in Texas I don't know if
you've seen the beach in Texas you're
exactly I love this state by the way
Florida and DeSantis has done a fabulous
job phenomenal job right so then you'll
have conversations with some folks and
they'll say you know look the scientists
should run 2028 he shouldn't run 2024.
he should just not even go in you know
he should wait till 2028 this is a the
Trump thing to do and Trump is upset
because he's not announced that he's not
running he's kept it open he's written
the book The Playbook of writing a book
go out there and do a couple interviews
Pierce Morgan all this stuff this is
sign up this guy's about to run so this
is why some of the people from the Trump
campaign saying you would be much better
if he stayed out possibly I I see it
both ways let me let me because I'm
friends with both of them first of all
it is it is a true statement that Ron
DeSantis would not have been the
Republican nominee without Trump he was
down 30 points to Adam Putnam in the
polls Putnam had all the I think it's
Adam Putnam is the name he raised all
the money he was Chamber of Commerce
selected and DeSantis got the
endorsement and he became the nominee
that there's a lot of Truth to that and
so Trump understandably feels like hey
man like I really helped you here right
look at the headline of the Tampa Bay
Times this is a left-wing paper fueled
by Trump Ron DeSantis easily beats Adam
Putnam despite 37 million dollars spent
on the primary more than twice what
DeSantis did right so there's a lot of
Truth to that and people forget that
okay now at the same time though
DeSantis is his own man and he's a great
governor with his own record and he's
done a unbelievably good job and so
Trump started him on his legacy there
but it's kind of an interesting thing
right it's like I kind of made you who
you are
wait your turn and DeSantis said ah well
you got me past the primary but you
didn't make me a good governor
right and so that's DeSantis claim
here's where I come down on it though my
advice to Ron DeSantis would be as of
right now you will not be the nominee
Trump is gaining support this indictment
helps him it validates every core
argument that Trump has which is the
system is against me therefore I'm such
a threat they're gonna try to take me
out in a Republican primary you know
that plays really really well I'm still
an outsider I'm still an outsider right
even though I'm the former president
running as a rebel right so it helps him
tremendously but I personally don't want
to see a nasty primary but I don't get
what I want it's going to be a nasty
primary I'm going to try to referee it
the best I can as friends with both of
them also wearing a Maga hat throughout
it as Trump 2024 with my commitments as
candidacy and what he wants to do for
the country but if Ronda santis wins if
Rhonda Santos runs he'll raise a bunch
of money and I hope you know we'll
Elevate the discourse and if and when he
loses which I believe he would lose the
Trump
I hope he endorses him question for you
this is the last question on this one no
I'm happy to go this one this one so so
if you were him and you beat Putnam
37 million to half you didn't have the
money that you raised Trump comes in
endorses you would you even signal that
you're running or would you come out and
say I'm not running this time around
what would you do if that was you I'd
probably run because there's this kind
of big shadow of a very big man Chris
Christie of the man who never ran and he
was supposed to be president in 2012 you
might remember he was kind of like the
darling of the Republican party and you
know then he hugged Obama and by the way
you know what's crazy you know what's
crazy because I think it's going to be
tough for uh Christie to cross that
bridge the bridge might be yeah exactly
yeah it might not hold his weight
um and so I'm sorry that's mean but it's
so true I mean he's like 200 pounds
overweight
lose the weight it's not that hard just
like stop eating carbs
um and so anyway the
that that kind of that kind of Shadow is
folklore in conservative world I hear it
all the time because Christy was a
popular governor who won in a state that
previously was not as favorable and so I
think if I was there in politics the
rule is it's better to run and lose than
to not run at all and be forgotten
Charlie this is why people like you
though okay so you're you're in a tough
spot here I had no idea what direction
you were gonna go about when I asked
those questions because you're you're
being super loyal to the man who helped
you during a time where you're 24 years
old Oval Office all these things that
you're talking to me trying to get your
business going and then you know it is
where it's at today but you're
maintaining a good relationship with
DeSantis and you're saying if he if you
had to be in his position you would
still run correct so in a way but at the
same time you are wearing the mega 2024
hat so Rahm Emanuel said the same thing
to Obama in 04 when it's like hey you
got all this momentum after the DNC
speech what are you going to do like
what's the likelihood that another
Moment Like This gonna happen to you
you're gonna be forgotten about and the
resume the santis has the last two and a
half three years of what he did under
Cove it's impressive it's it's more than
impressive it's number one on the
leadership correct yes but that doesn't
mean anything to the fact that this guy
named Donald is going to come that's
right at him in ways he's never
experienced before and it might toughen
him remember Ronald Reagan ran multiple
times for the Republican Presidential
nomination before actually being the
nominee Ronald Reagan primaried a
sitting President we forget this Gerald
Ford the unelected president only won in
American history he primaried him in
1976 and almost won the nomination
brought it to the convention floor and
then Gerald Ford won in kind of an
inside deal and then Ronald Reagan of
course won the nomination in 1980 and
won a landslide election and so you
asked me a very specific question if I
was him
and so I gave you a specific answer it's
better to run and lose than not run and
be forgotten will he lose oh yeah Trump
will I mean absent a Black Swan event or
massive amounts of Republican primary
voters you know changing their world
view in the next nine months which I
don't think is exactly going to happen I
have a really good pulse of the
Grassroots in the conservative
Grassroots they love Trump this
indictment has made them Furious they're
ready for action and they look at Donald
Trump as a symbol more than a man he is
a symbol of abuse of the powerful the
powerful coming after the normal person
and abusing them now Trump is not a
normal person he's a billionaire but
he's become kind of this Larger than
Life martyr where people who get fired
because their Factory went to China or
somebody that gets you know terminated
because they said something Politically
Incorrect Trump is a now manifestation
of the powerful using their powerful
unjustly you might disagree with that
representation but it's how millions of
Republican primary voters view it how
much does this infuriate
um a Hillary Clinton that she wishes she
had this kind of a following and this
kind of a admiration that she just
cannot get how much does this irritate
her I mean I could do a whole hour on
Hillary Clinton yeah she's a very broken
person
um and Donald Trump largely broke her
her whole life was about becoming
president her whole life from when she
went to Maine East High School in
Chicago when she went to Wellesley her
whole life was in preparation her
marriage to Bill Clinton what a con that
was right from her running the bimbo
squad for bill which was literally the
same thing that they're indicting Donald
Trump for Bill Clinton had a whole
operation a whole team you could look it
up bimbo Squad where they were just went
and they went to women that Donald Trump
um had not Donald Trump that Bill
Clinton had sex with and then they would
just do NDA after NDA after NDA
um and it was well known in the 90s and
people forget about it yep see Giuliani
says Clinton's in uh employed a bimbo
Squad you go down politico.com 2016. yes
Hillary was an enabler right she was the
chief architect she was a Michael Cohen
of Bill Clinton's NDA operation in the
90s and look I'll be very honest I don't
love the argument well Democrats do
those crimes and why should Republicans
be applied because I just think it's
overdone in this case it's actually a
good argument which is that Bill Clinton
mastered the private payoff NDA like he
was he was the best at it he would go
sleep with a woman she would go threaten
to go to the news and then he would
throw the bimbo Squad and settle for a
hundred thousand dollars right they
never indicted him and by the way while
we're talking about people's you know
sexual behaviors can we have maybe a
grand jury impaneled for Bill Clinton
getting on Jeffrey Epstein's plane and
going down because I guess former
presidents are now you know completely
fair game
it's also one side of the aisle right
this is the it was both sides on the
well no no Trump never went to the
island that is not true Trump and
Epstein hated each other there's a lot
of misinformation that Netflix did a lot
of damage here Trump kicked Epstein out
of the club he never went to the island
there's no evidence he ever engaged in
the Epstein's nonsense in fact he kicked
Epstein out because he was preying on
young women Bill Clinton did go to the
island dershowitz went to the island and
maybe some other people that's what we
know of but Trump never went to the
island
it's so funny that this this whole thing
takes place and nobody is willing to
open it up and go deeper to see what
really happened there you know what was
uh who do we have on a couple months ago
who talked about the Epstein Island Rob
who was who who do we have on what was
her name she was Whitney which by the
way she did a phenomenal job and she
can't even live in the states yeah they
loved what she had to say what what's
the likelihood that we'll ever in our
lifetime learn about what happened on
Epstein Island and you know any of the
guys that will be held accountable for
it what's the number below zero hmm
you really think it's not going to
happen at all oh yeah I mean so my my
hypothesis on Epstein he was an
intelligence asset either for the
American government or for the Israelis
he had a potemkin village of an
investment facade anyone that met him
there's a very powerful YouTube video
Eric Weinstein talks about this in
detail so this is not my theory he talks
about it he says when I sat down with
Jeffrey Epstein it makes sense because
he had the most expensive real estate
and he wasn't that sophisticated in how
he talked about Investments and there
were not a lot of recorded trades on the
addresses he disclosed for his financial
activity and he only had one investor
and it's all very strange right but it
makes sense that if you were trying to
run an intelligence operation either but
for the Saudis or for the Israelis or
for the American government that you
would try to get the most powerful
people in compromising situations of
underage girls capture it on film and
then be able to use it and blackmail for
blackmail so
I don't know all the details but you're
dealing with something that's deeper
than just kind of a high society pimp
that's essentially what Whitney Webb did
point out it was it wasn't even
necessarily Epstein it was his uh
right-hand woman yeah that her father
was undoubtedly some sort of asset from
Assad and he owned newspapers and he was
a Powerhouse Rupert Murdoch and him went
at it yeah that's exactly his name
Robert Maxwell yes so you're saying less
than zero percent right the fact that we
find out what actually happened on the
island it's not it's not gonna happen
who would lead that charge though you
know you see a January 6 committee or
911 committee but I mean that that the
only advocating for that only one person
could Trump no no no no it's it's it's
like yeah yeah oh uh uh what do you call
these uh um
Wikileaks guy uh Julian Assange
it's got to be somebody like that and
you got to be living in a different
place to pull it off and hack into it
and gather the community because they
have communicated so there's some way
somebody can't get to the island too
that's right Bill Gates went to the
island I'm sorry I forgot but Bill Gates
went to fix the Microsoft Outlook email
for Epstein because he was having
problems it wasn't just the island it
was this massive ranch in New Mexico too
right huge Ranch that underage girls
were trafficked to and remember this
wasn't just American government
officials
Prince Harry right is that it no not
Harry not Prince William Edward Prince
Edward Randy Andy yeah prince Andrew
Andrea call him again
no no Harry is yeah he's a whole
different from Santa Barbara yeah prince
Andrew
was also uh part of Epstein's orbit so
did you see uh uh just to bring up Harry
if you want to recognize them they're
non-profit they have to prove how many
hours a week they contribute total
nonprofit you know how many hours they
had to prove did you see it one hour a
week
nice that's hard work 11 million dollars
I believe they've raised what's 30
million dollars they've raised they've
given three million three million
dollars and they contribute an hour a
week to their charity that's some
hard-working people right there one
final thing on the Epstein thing I don't
mean to belabor the point but when I
first started to go to Palm Beach and I
visited Palm Beach 10 years ago I
started to hear kind of one-off comments
about oh yeah that house right there uh
that's Jeffrey Epstein and he's uh
trafficking young girls people knew in
the area and then you're 19 at the time
I was 19 20 years old yeah they would
just casually point this out no it was a
matter of fact because remember Epstein
was indicted like 15 years prior for
similar activity so it was kind of out
there right yeah uh I think it was a
cost to actually that was the U.S
attorney general ended up being one of
Trump's cabinet officials that was the
U.S attorney I could be wrong about that
but there was some connective tissue
there and anyway no one really took it
seriously and then I remember it was
either Rogan or somebody in 14 or 15
before all this started to talk about
Epstein's Island and you were smeared as
a conspiracy theory
as a cons if you would have said in 15
in public decent society that there was
a
targeted campaign with former presidents
and the world's richest man who Bill
Gates was at the time to go to a remote
island in the Caribbean to go be able to
have sex sexual relationships with
underage girls you would have been
laughed out of the room now we know
that's a fact why do I say that be
careful what you call a conspiracy
theory it's a thought-terminating cliche
that actually might lead you to
something by the way Rob I'm going to
send this to you I love what you just
said I'm going to send this to you can
you pull this up from APA news
uh uh because a lot of times you hear
things like this you're like well you
know conspiracy there are a lot of
conspiracy theorists out there and
you're seeing right now a lot of
conspiracy theorists saying you know
we're undefeated all these things came
true you know we were right exactly if
you but but look at the article it's not
written by Breitbart if you open this up
and you go to it conspiracy theory okay
coin long before JFK assassination go
lower to take a look at the article okay
claim the terms conspiracy theory were
created by CI agency following APS
assessment false recorded use of the
phrase conspiracy theory dates back to
1863 and it was notably invoked reports
following the 1881 shooting then
President James Garfield more than six
years before the CIA was established an
academic review of the digital library
found the term conspiracy theorist has
been published at least in the last what
what do you say to someone like this
where they're they're quick to jump on
it to say CI didn't come up with the
conspiration they're calling it a
conspiracy theory yeah conspiracy theory
came from the CIA go read the church and
Pike documents the church and Pike
committee was the most effective House
and Senate oversight of the U.S
intelligence agencies they received
death threats they were followed and
intimidated they came up with it so it's
not like we pulled it out of thin air
the church and Pike committee discovered
not just the heart attack gun which is a
real thing by the way they discovered a
gun that they could shoot somebody and
make it look like they had a heart
attack fake an autopsy but they
discovered that the Central Intelligence
Agency via operation Mockingbird a real
thing used the the term conspiracy
theory and got it into public opinion as
a way to try to discredit this opinion
it's in the church and Pike uh documents
so people can read it for themselves the
church and Pike committee was what year
did it was it 70 something yeah if I'm
not saying 76 right
um yeah I mean it's all there the
thousands of pages of documents that
most Americans aren't even aware of
you'll learn more about your government
cointel I can never pronounce right
cointelpro operation Mockingbird
um there's five or six of these projects
that the intelligence agencies are
running that the pike committee
uncovered
in your opinion all these conspiracy
theory stuff what turned out to be the
biggest
non-conspiracy Theory Epstein's out
there and and what do you think is
actually a conspiracy theory that
Americans like hey sorry to break it too
high versus truth is about yeah I hear
what you're saying go ahead
um well I mean there's there's several I
mean one of the ones we lived under in
the last couple of years was that
somehow closing schools and getting kids
away from each other is someone going to
stop the spread of the virus and if you
push back against it you're anti-science
and you're believing in conspiracy
theories right that's a really big one
um how about that the vaccine is safe
and effective and gonna stop
transmission I mean my mom got diagnosed
with covid today she had every booster
on the planet so I mean that was today
today I'm like how are you feeling
moment yeah out of nowhere I think that
I think there's a lot to the JFK
assassination I personally believe there
was more than one shooter I think
there's a lot of evidence to support
that we don't know that for a fact
because they keep on suppressing the
release of those documents
um I think that this idea that somehow
we got off a metallic-based current
currency just for good and Noble reasons
I think is insane just read the correct
the creature of Jekyll Island which is I
think one of the most Illuminating uh
books on currency Scott took his whole
team to Jekyll Island at one point did
you oh yeah we had a in the room where
they came up with the whole thing we had
a meeting there yeah so anyway but no I
mean there's there's several of them how
about this uh when we used to say that
there weren't weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq we were all called
conspiracy theorists turns out there
weren't
um they found some biological and
chemical agents but nothing near what
they told us it was right which was kind
of the core centerpiece of I think the
illegal mistake to invade Iraq one of
the worst mistakes in American history
what's on the flip side what do you mean
meaning like what actually probably is a
conspiracy theory oh um man you you guys
did we land on the Moon is the earth
round yes we do we do have a spherical
rounder yes yes that that that is
correct you could prove it
um and you could prove it mathematically
you could prove it flying in a plane you
could prove you could prove it when you
see a boat that all of a sudden just
discipline goes on the horizon that's
how you know you live on a spherical
round those are the dragons over the
edge yeah that's right that's why we
have to carve the uh the goddess in the
front of our boat to protect
usually landed on the moon yeah I do I
think we landed on the moon and the
reason being is that look it's I I don't
have any I'm gonna get so much hate mail
for this and that's fine but generally
that one seemed too big to cover up that
there would take too many people and too
many actors and too many fake stories
and I think there was a really good
MythBusters that actually went against
the kind of flag waving part of it again
I don't what about uh 911 I do not think
it was an inside job I think our
government probably had had
aforementioned notice yeah I think our
government probably probably knew that 9
11 was going to happen that they had
ignored intelligence reports there's too
much to suggest that we allowed the
hijackers into our country and we did
nothing to stop it so you do think it
was the inside that's not an inside job
necessarily an inside job would say that
the government was actively planning
explosives and wanted it to happen I
think that there was probably a turn of
the head on for whatever reason you
could figure it out we probably will one
day
um of some sort of domestic attack that
the ISL the Islamic fundamentalists were
plotting or planning but I think it goes
too far to say that our government was
planning explosives in the World Trade
Center I don't see any evidence I I want
to read a couple other stories here so
sure we can keep going into my opinion
crisis Crisis crisis like you know we
talked earlier about what's going to
happen what needs to happen for America
to be united we talk about different
crisis this is one of the ones that
you know a lot of people are calling me
about and asking me what do you think
about what's going to happen here and
it's coming up a lot lately China and
Brazil strike deal to ditch the US
dollar this is a zero head story and you
know they have reached a deal to trade
in their own currencies bypassing the US
dollar this deal will allow the two
countries to conduct their massive trade
which amounts to 150 billion per year in
financial transactions directly
exchanging one for riosis riosis uh vice
versa this deal is part of beijing's
latest move against the US dollar
extending its bilateral U.S dollar
attempting currency Arrangement Beyond
countries such as Russia Pakistan Saudi
Arabia to now include Latin American
exporting Powerhouse while we are still
strong long away from the one replacing
US dollar as a global Reserve currency
the current U.S ruling regime is
destroying the world's faith and
confidence
not only in the dollar but in what was
once a superpower in and is increasingly
a third world Banana Republic Tom
so I I think what most people need to
understand and this is where I think
Americans need to step back off
headlines and just learn something very
very quickly and that is 1944 there was
something called Brenton Woods and
that's where the U.S dollar was tied to
gold in other words the value of the US
dollar was connected to the value of
gold and between Fort Knox and other
areas we had gold reserves so the U.S
currency on a global scale was deemed as
being valuable tied to gold and stable
and in 1944 everyone came to this
agreement to say hey let's Peg the value
of our currency to the dollar because
the dollar is pegged to gold and it
brought International global stability
it also created the dollar as the
world's Reserve currency well what does
that mean that means if you have extra
reserves and you bought them in dollars
they were stable because they were tied
to the gold now Nixon we can talk about
what you just referenced a minute ago
was Nixon taking us off the gold
standard 72-73 which had nothing to do
with the Vietnam War and political
instability in the economy at that time
it was deeper I'm with you it was deeper
reasons that was the front excuse
the right now you know what the average
is right now on world reserves 62 of
countries reserves are held in U.S
dollars 62 right now and so even though
we went off the gold standard were the
reserve currency so people see the
United States currency as very stable
that's what's important and what we're
seeing here is the wand everybody here
is the one and well that's a unit of
measure the actual currency in China is
called the raminbi that's their dollar
dollar equals remind me one is like a
unit
and so what they want is they want to
slowly remember trying to place a long
game they want to slowly replace the
dollar as the world's Reserve currency
because they succeed huh well they
succeed well they're taking one step at
a time and they're starting with African
nations that they put into by the way
you can also go study mercantilism where
you come in and you take all the
resources and then you sell them back
things that are made out of the
resources so China is in an active state
right now of assisting many small
Regional Latin American and African
nations on deals that are intentionally
going to go bad and then leave them with
the collateralization of the country
they've just
pillaged and so long term if somebody
doesn't stand up long-term sure China
could be successful because they're
playing this not the way the West plays
it the West has played the game in terms
of history in terms of regimes a regime
of leadership China is playing this long
term in terms of of decades
what do you think oh sorry
yeah I don't mean interrupt uh I agree I
think the dollar it's gonna it's gonna
hit a flat line because Germany South
Korea and Japan are not going to drop
the dollars of world Reserve currency
and especially Germany and Japan uh they
pre they produce a lot of value and a
lot of wealth and so the Euro
backstopping the world Reserve current
meaning the dollar being the backstop of
the euro is actually in our benefit but
India is going to be the big question
right if India Falls that's a growing
Market Brazil is a totally corrupt
country they're a broken country the
Bulls on Brazil have been wrong the last
20 years it's like a trillion dollar GDP
you could fact check me on it they're
mainly a natural resource Hub and they
have a real hard time with their own
homegrown industry and there was like
1.6 trillion I was about right uh it's
actually flatlined and gone down in
recent years so the Bulls on Brazil have
been wrong and with Lula now becoming
president they're going to become a
wholly owned colony of the Chinese
Communist Party basically that's what
catastrophic for the nation it's
terrible yeah the future of Brazil is
put in permanent Jeopardy because of
bolsonaro not be you know staying as
president prime minister and everybody
thought brick through the 90s was just
an acronym for emerging Nations you know
Brazil Russia India China it wasn't it
was a coalition over there that wanted
to undermine U.S Authority on the global
trade basis so we need a new president
because I don't think Joe Biden seems
awfully worried that the dollar is no
longer becoming the world Reserve
currency you couldn't say that it wasn't
a good idea for us to become the world
Reserve currency however it's a fact
that if we stop being the world Reserve
currency every single person in America
gets significantly poor overnight the
fact that people have to turn their
goods and services into dollars is kind
of a stimulus boost just baked into our
economy we're we're kind of a we're a
place of Last Resort a refuge if you
will it's a built-in advantage that we
don't even recognize or realize till we
travel the world but I think we have
more staying power than people realize
there's a lot of entrepreneurs we create
a lot of value in this country as some
very valuable companies despite the fact
that we're service based we still have a
lot of Natural Resources we have a
manufacturing Beast that can still be
Unleashed if necessary so we have a lot
of advantages with that being said
though this current Administration seems
unbothered by any of this and I mean
what we need is a new regime you're
right we do think in time in terms of
regime hopefully it's president Trump
and we go directly after the CCP but a
lot of this is centered on a border
dispute on eastern Ukraine all of this
is it if that was not happening the way
it was happening a lot of these chips
would not be falling into place in my
opinion that is the beginning Domino
because then Russia said okay screw you
we're going to go grow closer to China
you know we're no longer for the first
time ever Russia has just dropped
basically all their dollars out of the
central bank because we made them when
we put sanctions on them by the way what
is that what does that say for World
Reserve currency status is why our
leaders are so stupid we basically
confiscated the dollars out of the
Russian Central Bank that's not exactly
safe and secure basically countries are
saying wait a second you can just
confiscate our dollars like we went
after them and just grabbed the dollars
and said Yep they're no longer valid you
know converted into ruples and Russia
said okay well that's an act of War
which it is
and so I think a lot of this is centered
on this Eastern you know border dispute
we could talk about that if you'd like I
think it's incred incredibly important I
don't think people have really thought
through the ramifications
of our involvement in Ukraine and then
when G comes over and says hey I have a
plan B for you in this currency thing
tell you what let's take something
really valuable I've got it energy yeah
I need energy and energy has a hard unit
of value coming out of the ground just
like gold does and so what XI did is he
got value in the form of resources for
the raminbi in a in a deal that looks
like a trade deal but it's a currency
deal with Russia right yeah it's it's
bad all across the board but make no
mistake with the proper president the
right President we can crack that
Alliance in nine months these countries
China has a lot of domestic what would
Trump do so okay you're saying that so
Trump gets a let's just say it's 2024.
he wins what's he doing well first he
could go back to what we already had
which is you have a piece immediately
brokered in eastern Ukraine immediately
you go in there and you end the stupid
War you end this proxy war you you then
try to create intentional separation
between Russia and China and keep them
in their own Corners you go to the
Saudis and you say knock it off you
you're going to keep on using the dollar
for the Petro dollar you save OPEC which
will increase the dollar strength as a
world Reserve currency and then you have
to go after the CCP in like a 15 Point
targeted plan you pull their visas from
being able to go to Europe you put
targeted sanctions on them there's
there's again I'm not exactly saying
anything that hasn't been thought
through through really serious Scholars
but we have to have a serious plan to
punish the CCP for what they did with
the virus covering it up and lying about
it and then also their hyper aggressive
action with Belton Road cyber warfare
infiltrating the American economy some
of that comes with a price and a cost
but then more than anything else Trump
if he becomes president again will be
energy independent again there'll be
economic confidence restored I think
that we'll see inflation put under
control because we'll actually have a
rebirth of Market stability right now
people are confused they're uncertain
they're afraid of their own shadow
everyone's looking what the central bank
is doing
entrepreneurs can't operate in an
environment like this and that's why
you're seeing business startups go down
you're seeing acquisition slow down
whether in a recession or not I think we
are in a recession it really is an
indictment of the lack of confidence
coming from the current regime we don't
know if a big tax bill is going to be
passed we don't know if The Regulators
are going to be thrown at us we need
president Trump to do what he did for
four years which is to unshackle the
American economy
don't leave out Taiwan is that the
question between China and Taiwan is
market share of semiconductors this got
nothing to do with righting wrong on
Chiang Kai-shek yeah that's correct
that's why we should build as many
domestic semiconductor plants this is
not lost on Donald J Trump and Taiwan
will not happen that Taiwan won't happen
that way and they know it and they know
old Portuguese name for it yeah my
question to Charlie is this
I'm glad you brought up the acronym
brick which I think has now been updated
to Bricks because uh Brazil Russia India
China and now South Africa is now the
latest
South Africa
um all facetious is right there I don't
mean to make fun of South Africa it's
not exactly a world power Elon Musk is
going to be very upset when he hears you
uh commenting on his name I think you
would agree this is an African American
Natural here's my question I don't think
there was anything like China was going
to do this regardless we know that
they've been trying to come after the
American superpower and that's just
what's on their agenda China 2030.
Russia was never going to Cozy up to
America they're always going to be
aligned with China in some regard my
question is India I don't I don't think
China and India are aligned whatsoever
not natural Partners so they're not
natural parishes whatsoever exactly so
what's their role in this because I
always thought that they as the the most
populated democracy in the world yeah
outside of America where is India's role
in that not that you're this
india-pacific expert but no I mean I
seem to have a very good look I mean
India is a tricky country you can't
trust their government they're doing
deals with Iran and they're doing all
sorts of weird stuff for energy but
India should be the most natural partner
in hedge you could squeeze China through
a bilateral agreement with Korea Japan
and India and that's why America needs
to be actively involved in the room and
calling balls and Strikes using
sanctions and tariffs were necessary and
using the global Reserve currency status
to be able to effectuate meaningful
geopolitical change which of which you
know we do not have right now I disagree
a little bit I think Russia's run by a
bunch of thugs and Mobsters I think
Russia wants whatever is best for Russia
I don't think necessarily Russia and
China are these natural Partners I think
we made it that way I think what Donald
Trump was trying to do was he was trying
to keep Russia in some sort of a kind of
ambiguous middle neutral area phase and
then jab at China remember Trump put he
put sanctions on China he you know
improved a lot of diplomatic diplomats
be expelled from China he was putting a
lot of different he was trying to kind
of create some form of a jab against the
CCP the problem right now is the CCP is
able to run undeterred right now there
there is no counterbalance from America
so I mean look for example if we had an
actual regime that cared about saving
America like okay China you're going
down to Brazil to go do a new deal 15
export now tariff immediately on pick
your product just make him feel it a
little bit a little bit of you know make
them think twice he said there's no
there's no cost to it and look China has
a lot of domestic problems they have
hundreds of millions of people living in
legitimate third world poverty despite
the appearance that Gigi ping puts on
like he's the most popular leader ever
there's legitimate dissent against the
CCP the CCP is run by a group of
mobsters and thugs with no more than
five percent of the popular support and
so they got their own ticking Time Bomb
they have ghost cities they manipulate
their currency they have Bank runs that
happen far too often they suppress a lot
of the news there they're not a free
Society they think they can kind of do
this Marxist orwellian digital
surveillance State I actually think
that's unsustainable I think it's going
to break eventually I could be wrong and
so China likes to posture as this really
strong man we could destabilize the
Chinese Communist party in nine months
with a proper president
um the question is do we want to the
only question then is why don't we it's
because they've captured our Elites and
they call it Elite capture in actually
Mandarin they have purchased the head of
the NBA they purchased the Wall Street
they purchase you know the top people
Peter Schweitzer put this in his book
red-handed where he talks about about
how the American Elites are bought and
paid for by the CCP there's a great
expression in Mandarin and it's roughly
translated uh little bad talk big help
which means they might talk a bad game
against China but they're a big Act of
help
um you look at the cover he has Elon
Musk on there which I think is a little
unfair but he has Joe Biden John Boehner
Nancy Pelosi LeBron James I think that's
Henry Kissinger and then Bill Gates all
of which we benefit tremendously from
the Chinese Communist party and then you
see what happens when like a famous
American actor like John Cena steps out
of line yep immediately put back into
place in uh Mandarin or the NBA was
regulating who could wear things in the
stands of free uh free Hong Kong
protester shirts remember that it's kind
of a story that was suppressed a couple
years ago with Daryl Moore yeah you were
not allowed to even go into a National
Basketball Association game with free
Hong Kong t-shirts so it's a hyper I
mean you think about it it's
these associations Hollywood especially
Hollywood Banking and sports are the
three major industries that are
controlled by the Chinese Communist
Party Hollywood there's more than that
attack two but not even as much as
Hollywood Banking and sports
fact that we're being apologetic to them
like Hey we're so sorry what can we do
to make you happy and you can easily and
you America helped China become who they
are today with the relationships over
the years yeah I mean I don't mean
interject but without us giving them
favored nation status without the 1999
World Trade Organization treaty they are
a third world country yeah period and we
basically said okay we're going to read
domicile our manufacturing assets we're
going to close down our ability to make
stuff and we're going to do this massive
labor Arbitrage where we're going to set
we're going to send all the jobs to you
and we get a bunch of plastic we do not
need in return and the robber barons
that made those deals and I don't say
that lightly because I'm a capitalist
but it was bad for the West
design this entire thing and but when
you have a relaxed monetary currency
which we do it necessitates
neoliberalism who are The Architects of
that deal in 1999
um well Bill Clinton signed it but it
was largely driven by Consultants
McKenzie and Company was the largest
company that was basically pushing
um you know the kind of idea that we're
going to go to a company and say we'll
be able to solve you see right there
McKinsey and Company right there it was
that 2019 yeah and we're going to go in
we'll save you you know Pennies on a
dollar you know you could make this
Trinket in China for this even this tie
right here is made in China I was like
wearing it early are you kidding me why
can't we make this here it's because you
know we want to try to get the lowest
cost and for certain products it made
sense but why do we make penicillin and
vitamin C 90 of all our vitamin C comes
from China like that makes no sense and
so we we offshored our critical
infrastructure to a country that seemed
to be kind of a passive country and it's
now turned into our greatest enemy and
what have we gained from that just lower
prices when you go to Walmart I'll tell
you what we've gained our homes are
twice as big as they were in the 1950s
with twice as much garbage that we do
not use and they're half as they're half
filled they're twice as empty because we
have less kids so we have we have piles
of plastic we do not use and factories
that are empty and then in return we
fill our entire communities with
fentanyl made by the Chinese Communist
Party pumped through by the sinola drug
cartel and we lose 107 000 people a year
to drug overdoses and we'll take another
step closer to home and I'll teach I'm
teaching people new words today Pat
mcciladora mequiladora means little
sister maquiladora was the concept of
putting a small Factory in Mexico where
the labor was cheaper and products could
be made and then they would take a very
short walk to the United States so if
that WTO deal doesn't happen in favor of
China it would have turned Mexico into
the larger manufacturing power and what
would have happened to the Mexican
economy you would have had the eruption
the good eruption of the middle class in
Mexico and you can trace it right back
to the issues that we have with Mexico
to the gang style violence that there
are in terms of controlling government
areas in Mexico whereas if this happened
you would have turned them into to 1950s
United States manufacturing power and
what would have that done to our
relationship with Mexico it would have
made our continent a superpower
continent is what it would have done why
did not we have the foresight to do
something like that because you could
make it for cheaper they were chasing
the labor costs
and and I hate to be that blunt but the
Chinese Communist Party basically said
pennies per wage hour
for us to be able to make a shoot and
they were chasing the wage hour and look
I'm a capitalist I'm a free market guy
but also I want markets to point towards
something virtuous and good and not
every deal you do is going to always
beep in that proper context the Chinese
Communist Party deal is a bad deal and
the people that defend it
it's indefensible I mean what we have as
a casualty is we have become more in
like an owned and operated colony of the
CCP it's breakable it's breakable for
many reasons because we still have a
free society and they don't the fact we
have somewhat of a free Society is our
great competitive advantage that right
there is how we beat them if you
unshackle the American entrepreneur we
run circles around these people because
you cannot possibly quantify or measure
20 or 30 million free people taking
risks that will be to CCP oligarch every
day that's a planned economy now they
have a mixed economy but they still are
not figuring out entrepreneurship there
because they have to comp they have to
control they have to confiscate wealth
it's still fear-based a true free
Society economically could destroy these
guys in a decade and what you don't
realize is you're seeing a reflection of
1950s and 60s Soviet Union where they
tried to put in place these five-year
economic plans centered around crop
plans and Agriculture and we're going to
export to Europe and that's where we're
going to get our power out of it and
they they had a couple things they had
uranium they had limited lnc because of
the extraction that they were doing at
that time blah blah blah blah well guess
what that is exactly what you're seeing
happen here is these limited economic
plans that are based on control of the
populace the labor force are not working
for China just the same way they didn't
work for this is the Soviet Union can I
ask you a question Pat because I know
this is something that's near and dear
in your heart obviously you know
entrepreneurship capitalism the back
backbone of what valuetainment is all
about you've interviewed whether it's
General Robert Spalding countless people
that the uh what's the one gentleman
that you've had multiple times the he's
the expert in China relations
So when you say that China is fear-based
and Charlie corrected out uh you know
you have 20 30 million entrepreneurs in
America that can spur American
exceptionalism again great economically
what where do you like what do you when
you say fear-based with China versus a
perfect idea so so if I go to TSA Pre to
get my TSA pre-card you're in fear
because you're dealing with a government
organization customer service is
non-existent the lady's talking to me as
if I work for her I told you to be here
50 minutes ago I'm like you got to be
kidding me I'm driving up Are you
seriously yes I told you I'm like wow
then go to clear you go to clear you
know how they'll talk to you oh my god
thank you so much for coming and thank
you for this and thank you for that Rob
if we can grab a bottle of water so
clear will give you customer service
because they want your business TSA Pre
knows you don't have a choice you best
respect us right fear free TSA fear
clear but free America is free still
China is fear you're afraid walking
around you got to make that guy happy
this guy happy that guy happy this guy
happy it's all about that this is why
some by the way earlier question I asked
of you guys and I asked Charlie uh Kelly
you can just bring it up earlier
question I asked of a uh Charlie I said
what would happen thank you to America
today if
Elon doesn't buy Twitter
if Spotify doesn't drop if Spotify drops
Rogue let's say and a rumble isn't there
what would happen
entrepreneurs are going to fix 95 of the
world's problems because in climates
like this you don't think YouTube in
their board meetings they're talking
about Rumble right now what do you think
they're talking about you don't think
Facebook and YouTube and all those guys
are sitting there pissed off at Elon for
allowing freedom of speech you don't
think there's you don't think YouTube
and all the Silicon Valley people are
not pissed off at Sweden Daniel if we're
not dropping Rogan how dare you not drop
Rogan how dare you not drop Rogan
capitalist expose bad arguments and
that's what what's happening right now I
want to transition into a couple other
things as a parent of seven months yes
seven months which is exciting
life-changing life you can all your your
eyes man tell a story right now I
remember having our first yeah as
parents you know uh you think about
these things now where before when you
were single you're like maybe it's not
as big of a deal Biden says transgender
people shape our nation's soul
I've never heard this before in official
Proclamation okay
President Biden's issued an official
Proclamation uh declaring March 31st as
the transgender day of visibility
stating that transgender Americans shape
our nation's soul and contribute to
society in various Fields including the
military medicine politics and business
he also Express expressed concern over
discriminatory state laws targeting
transgender Youth and the epidemic of
violence against transgender women and
girls particularly women and girls of
color anyways he keeps going on and on
and you see what you know Jean-Pierre
Korean Jean-Pierre was talking about and
then I saw a clip I want to play this
clip for you if you can Rob if you can
play play that clip uh off of Twitter
and I want to get your reaction this
this kid is 11 years old I'm sure you've
seen this he gets up there speaking to
the board then his father speaks
afterwards can you play this clip real
quick Rob how my name is Knox zajak uh
I'm 11 years old and I go to
Middle School I'm a sixth grader I was
in the library and
this book was on a stand I'd like to
read you a page
my back over my hips as I ask if we
should take off take our clothes off and
he's saying yes before I finish my
sentence he's pulling off my t-shirt
laughing when I can't undo his shirt
buttons he's undoing my belt I'm
reaching into his bedside I thought you
got another video playing in the
background Rob
yeah you got some kind of another clip
plane in the background a lot of tabs
open
yeah you got one other clip that because
that music doesn't match it it's kind of
strange yeah very strange
yeah exactly in a exactly the same way
you're thinking about it I'm thinking
about it that doesn't fit no okay go
back to it and play it
no you still got another clip playing
Rob I'm happy to comment on it yeah go
ahead comment on him until he finds the
video look this is happening in school
districts across the country basically
the kid goes on to read an incredibly
graphic and pornographic piece of
literature that is presented prominently
in a middle school library and they said
it was like the first book when he
walked in which is insane it's outright
grooming and his father comes up
afterwards and oh his father was yeah I
do not mean to make this political
because it should not be political but I
will make it political because Ron
DeSantis to his great credit said that
is no place in schools and they called
him a book Banner the Democrat Party
says that's okay and that needs to
really set into people again I I hope
it's not political I don't think most
Democrats even support that crap but as
a political issue they went after Ron
DeSantis for trying to say this has no
place in our schools and you read this
you listen to this graphic telling and
by the way that's one of thousands of
examples that we have found there is a
targeted campaign that is reflected in
some pieces of legislation now in
California to say that it's okay to rob
a child of their innocence it's not a
big deal in fact it's a good thing
see the problem Rob do you have it now
or if you can play it I want I want to
see him reading this the reaction go to
yeah go to
10 seconds into it there you go press
play without the grader yeah I was in
the library and
this book was on a stand I'd like to
read you a page
my back over my hips as I ask if we
should take off take our clothes off and
he's saying yes before I finish my
sentence he's pulling off my t-shirt
laughing when I can't undo his shirt
buttons he's undoing my belt I'm
reaching into his bedside drawer for a
condom we're kissing again we're rolling
over obviously you can see where this is
going I don't know if it's because we're
feeling especially emotional or just
tired or these past couple of weeks have
been too much but this reminds me so
much of the first time we had sex we
were both [__] terrified and the
whole thing was kind of terrible because
we didn't know what we were doing
good too so good because we were a mess
of emotions and we were scared and
excited and everything felt new so this
sort of thing this sort of feels like
that Nick touches me like he's scared at
any minute
now this book was at my middle school
and it was on a stand when I rented it
out to show my dad it uh the librarian
asked if I wanted more and if I wanted a
graphic novel version
that's a comic book but of course I I'm
I'm only shocked people are surprised
this is this is everywhere
okay good I was asking for you yeah I'll
take another three minutes so that's my
son okay 11 years old and went to his
library and found that
by the entry door
of our library this is the smut that he
is finding all right I don't care
whether it's gay straight bisexual
whatever the terms are for all this
stuff doesn't need to be at our school
doesn't need to be at my 11 year old's
library and then as far as genderqueer
I've got a son in the high school as
well and this is [__] We Know It All
right we do not need to be having
literature that's showing boys how to
suck dick all right this is a very very
frustrated about it okay and you may
think that schools know the best for our
children you know who know the best for
our children the parents
this is not an isolated example there's
thousands and thousands no no doubt
about this is why gays against groomers
are doing what they're doing we had them
on two weeks ago yeah so but but for me
you know how uh uh historically there
are some arguments that Republicans lost
where they lost 92 of the black vote
when they lost it Barry Goldwater you
look at how some arguments where you
know you lost the Hispanic vote because
hey they're for this this is the kind of
thing that could dramatically turn
parents against the Democratic vote
because it say somebody that just votes
just to vote and they don't think about
all the details that's going on but they
said wait a minute I'm voting for this
and that's what the Democrats support I
just don't support that so they may go
independent they may go I know earlier
today you were saying Joe manchin was on
uh a show where they were asking how are
you is there any chance that you could
run and he said hey you may run as an
independent yeah there's going to be
opportunities to look elsewhere because
the Democratic party argument
today is losing a lot of logical
arguments for parents
I completely agree
I think it's a opportunity for the uh
for the other side to make the
presentation to connect with the parents
couple other stories before we wrap up I
want to talk about this wonderful
capitalist I don't know if you've ever
heard of him he's won the best
capitalists out there uh who uh uh it's
becoming a little bit more proud and
proud to talk about it his name is
Bernie Sanders if you've heard this guy
before why doesn't he give his book away
for free yeah he's got a net worth
somewhere between five to eight million
dollars he was upset when when he was
called out on it earlier I want you to
play the clip first Rob of what happened
with him and the uh what's his name Mark
Wayne Mullen when they're going back and
forth just play the first uh if you can
uh I don't know if you have the clip
it's the Forbes clip I send it to it's
on YouTube it's not on uh it's not on
it's a YouTube link I sent you if you go
on YouTube and you type in Bernie
Sanders and you type in his name Mark
Wayne Mullen you'll see it
and it's go to the second one the seven
minute one yeah obviously we're not
gonna watch the whole thing but I want
you to start it off so first of all they
cut off Howard uh Schultz the founder of
Starbucks he lets him finish his thought
he finishes the story then he comes back
and go about 20 seconds into it and
press play and then we want to see the
last minute
as you might imagine go a little bit
further until you're curious to
understand what happened right there
your anti-union as a CEO you're you're
anti-union busting or your four union
busting I'm not saying you're anti-union
I'm just saying that it seems like to me
as a former CEO not nearly at the
success that you were at sir and I'm not
trying to defend your company uh because
quite frankly politically we're on
totally different ends of the spectrum
and so the irony of this hearing is
actually kind of this guy's worth around
70 million I do want to point out some
hypocrisy about this hearing with the
chairman that's not trying to get
personal all this information is going
to be very public but the fact that you
can't defend your company because you
want to have a good relationship with
your employees and you believe in
employee value which we all do any CEO
knows it's success of our companies are
based on our employees we get that but
it seems like unions today all they want
to do is fight with the with the with
their their employees or their employer
the same employer that is hiring those
those team members
and that friction causes a a very
volatile and and and and and tough
workplace and if the company and the
employees aren't can you go in 10
seconds keep going 10 seconds
eight million keep going and and and
unions just test the 10 seconds
but I take offense to the to the the
chairman pointing out all CEOs are
corrupt because they're millionaires
you know if you make a lot of money
you're you're corrupt if yet it's it's
bothering to me because Mr chairman you
yourself have been very successful
rightfully so glad you haven't you've
been in office for 28 years and your
wife has have immersed a wealth of over
eight million dollars and and in fact
your quote on on on being on being
wealthy and being a millionaires was
well if you write a bestseller you can
be a millionaire too
If You Can Be A Millionaire why can't Mr
Schultz and other CEOs be millionaires
and be honest too
if that's the case then why is it that
missile Schultz who actually creates
jobs and a bestseller of a book isn't
creating any jobs
why is it that he's corrupt and you're
not straight up when Adam why is it that
all CEOs are corrupt because they're
wealthy and yet our chairman who is
wealthy and I'm glad you are
you're not
so fast forward not when they have their
back and forth and he's trying to defend
it says this is the most ridiculous
thing I've ever seen to be keep going
there you go right there go ahead thank
you well let me respond this the senator
did mention my name I think
and I think you got an all-time record
here you've made more misstatements in a
shorter period of time than I have ever
heard please correct well if I'm worth
eight million excuse me no public excuse
me yeah go ahead all right Excuse me yes
sir but I'm worth eight million dollars
that's good news to me
I'm not aware of it that's a lie all
right number two third of public records
you're probably looking at some phony
right-wing into net stuff it ain't true
no uh you should read beyond that it is
not true it's all right public records
no it is not public right okay well you
made it not a million on your public
records I've got the mic down number two
okay you can pause it here I'll get some
comments and then I'm gonna show one
minute clip and then we'll wrap it up go
ahead when you see something like this
with Bernie going after guys like Howard
Schultz who's you know creative 400 2
000 jobs what do you think about this
exchange I'm an entrepreneur you're an
entrepreneur creating values hard and it
takes risk and you need capital and you
need labor you need a balance between
the two but you have not you have no
value created unless you have an
individual with a drive and the ambition
to work the extra nights wake up the
early mornings and assume all of the
responsibility you see all Bernie looks
at is the advantage but he does not
realize lies that at any time when he
was CEO of Starbucks while he was the
sole owner he could have been open to
lawsuits he could have been open to you
know Mass client walkouts and if it goes
bankrupt who's the one that then has to
go to bankruptcy court or the employees
that's going to Bankruptcy Court no they
go find another job no but when you're
an entrepreneur you're not saying okay I
want the upside but I want the downside
and guess what most of businesses in
America go to the downside Direction
they do not succeed that doesn't mean
they go bankrupt but they shutter they
fold or they get bought or they just
kind of tape her out and so it's very
easy to criticize Howard Schultz and I
have a lot of problems with Starbucks as
a company politically but that is a
unbelievably hard business to scale I
can't think of I mean maybe your
business Patrick might be harder but I
mean
it's pretty impressive but I mean I
gotta be honest insurance is harder than
coffee but think about it the late it's
labor intensive yeah it's a he turned a
commodity into something that was
special so coffee was never something
that was you know considered to be an
experience are worth paying up for so he
he up sold something that was just so
widespread that people would have in
their homes and you have to hire
hundreds of thousands of people the
turnover is immense you got to train
them you have to have the rent the and
you got to scale it against also once
you create the genre of coffee service
immediately of a thousand competitors
right Dunkin Donuts changed their model
Krispy Kremes and he still stayed
excellent and so McDonald's built Cafe
yes that's right and he still pummeled
them and he still did a good job and
their coffee's not even that good at
Starbucks and he kept on doing it and I
mean I don't think it's very good
compared to most other but I think it's
admirable the way Howard Schultz
defended himself because he said look I
earned that money and that's my one of
my favorite words in the English
language that's right is earned that's
right and he tried to cut him off by
that's right and Bernie Sanders has not
earned anything yeah now he might have
some book deals or whatever but Bernie
Sanders has never because he's a bum he
was a bum mayor of Burlington he was a
bummed failed congressman and he's a bum
Senator he's never created any value in
his life where he's got to say you know
what I'm gonna take risk I'm going to
assume responsibility to create
voluntary
value or someone's going to want to
transact with me and so Bernie Sanders
enjoys being rich he does not know what
it takes to get there but it's really
the core element of the Socialist
um world view resentment I want to show
this so for the longest time I love that
by the way for the longest time he would
always criticize millionaires
millionaires and billionaires
Millionaires and billionaires
Millionaires and billionaires there's
this one minute clip that was done by
Think Progress they're no longer around
it was done it was ran by a guy named
Judd I want to say and you know they
were more on the Hillary Clinton side so
they did not like a socialist getting
the momentum that we're getting for
American progress so he made this video
this one minute video on Twitter if you
can go to it with the timeline it's not
this one Rob if you can find it he made
this one minute video it's just go to my
Twitter go back to my Twitter account
and uh if if you
oh you should find it Rob if you again
this is when I text you as well
right there right there if you can zoom
out on that one now watch this when you
zoom out
okay play from the beginning just watch
when he stops saying millionaires
so if I'm a millionaire what
Millionaires and billionaires it's a
billionaires and millionaires the
Millionaires and billionaires
[Music]
see this when he gets the ball
proliferation of millionaires and
billionaires now watch Millionaires and
billionaires of millionaires and
billionaires billionaires and
billionaires
billionaires Millionaires and
boom now he's a millionaire 2016. this
is a budget of the billionaire class by
the billionaire class and for the
billionaire class but enough about Union
as in his administration billionaires
billionaires and the wealthiest people
billionaires and the wealthy a handful
of billionaires another billionaires
billionaires allow billionaires
multi-millionaires
of multi-millionaires and billionaires
one percent
we will be an Administration For the
Working Families of this country and not
for billionaire campaign contributors
the day he becomes a billionaire would
be called the trillionaires I mean
that's that's his formula right there on
what he does Charlie you see someone
like that what do you think about
I got a lot of work to do because he
influences a lot of young people and
it's very easy to be generous of other
people's money value is hard to come by
a free society allows people to use
their reason and their agency and their
abilities to create something Hilo out
of nothing and we live in the wealthiest
most prosperous Society ever for a
reason and he's trying to stop that his
ideas are directly against what has made
the society so wealthy and prosperous
and which really is that entrepreneurial
underbelly but what's Charlie's uh
long-term Vision to wrap up is for me
does Charlie Kirk have any vision of one
day being a president I don't know I I
no but the I get ants I get asked all
the time Charlie are you going to run
for office all this I love what I get to
do I do three hours of radio every day
we're one of the most successful
podcasts out there please subscribe
everybody if you can you can take out
your Apple podcast And subscribe put the
link below Rob so we can make sure to
continue that would bless me thank you
the Turning Point USA or is that Charlie
Kirk and I'll get to that yeah so I I
love what I I I love to educate I love
to learn I love to read all weekend and
then try to distill those ideas in ways
that people can understand that's where
I'm my most passionate and then we have
Turning Point USA which is our movement
of hundreds of thousands soon to be
millions of people that believe in
freedom fighting for it and so I'd
rather be a movement leader and a
thought leader than just a politician
that that's where I find myself to have
the biggest impact and the most Joy but
we don't know right and you got to keep
a little bit open you don't know what's
going to happen well first of all I
can't I'm 29 years old so I can't
legally Run for the presidency six more
years I don't want to be president I
think it would be a crummy job I have a
lot of work to do okay it'd be a crummy
job think about it I mean it it depends
under the circumstances but you gotta
you got non-stop pressure you got the
Deep State coming in yeah you like it
though you like a fight I mean I do love
the fight that's the job of a fight I'm
not going to run for president I'm not
doing that the thing is today they came
out with uh some somebody that
researched here they're saying the
average person there's going to be
people born today that are going to live
up to 104 40 years so essentially we
have 111 more years to go like in the
days of Noah literally in the scriptures
they say you're going to be living in
the days of Noah now I know we're living
in the days the suns were a hundred when
they went on that's right that's exactly
right I'll say one thing to you I've
seen a ton of your Clips online I
completely appreciate how you walk into
enemy territory and hold people
accountable and a lot of times their
their arguments are
just emotional and you have logic and
facts on your side so that's respect
um what campuses can we see you on
coming up I think you're a very
necessary voice especially where we see
the direction that gen Z is going what's
uh what's that looking like in the
future yeah so we just finished our
campus tour I did my mostly peaceful
campus visit at University California
Davis where they they sent antifa and
they came with weapons and made big news
Elon Musk commented on it it was all
over the place uh but we just finished
our campus tour uh we have some big
events coming up they can go to
tpusa.com start a high school or a
college chapter returning Point USA that
is our movement uh it's the Crux of
everything I do and we do
um the field program is the largest ever
Pro freedom field program in the history
of the country and we have people that
disagree with us in fact if you look at
our campus events where I'm really proud
of this anytime I speak anywhere I have
anyone who disagrees go to the front of
the line and in fact I tell the crowd
not to boo them or Heckle them I love
the fight I love dialogue in fact I
think that's what makes us human
dialogue literally means through reason
through the logos I think when we stop
talking we go into a totalitarian you
know dystopia and I think we have to
have more difficult conversations lean
into the topics that are considered to
be politically incorrect or third rail
um and it makes life fun and interesting
and worth living I think Charlie it's
it's been great having you on like Adam
said we we agree you're a very very
necessary voice thank you and you're
gonna be a force to be reckoned with for
decades to come whether it's an office
or doing what you're doing or something
new who knows what's going to happen but
we're looking forward to it either way
thank you appreciate you for coming on
gang if you're watching this make sure
to go click on the link below subscribe
to his podcast follow him with all the
links that that we have below take care
everybody bye-bye bye-bye